[Musique]
bonjour bah écoutez je suis vraiment
vraiment ravi d'être avec vous
aujourd'hui et vous raconter mon
histoire un petit peu justement l'envers
du décor et justement je vais démarrer
un peu par par mon éducation et mes
parents parce que c'est ça qui a fait
mon caractère et la personne que je suis
aujourd'hui en fait mes parents ont fait
un choix assez incroyable c'est qu'ils
ont décidé de ne jamais me scolarisés je
suis pas du tout contre l'école je fais
en train de vous dire ne pas aller à
l'école mais ils ont fait un choix d'un
que c'est à dire qu'ils m'ont jamais
scolarisé même pas une journée en
maternelle parce que pourtant on n'avait
pas d'argent n'étaient pas voilà je n'ai
pas d'expérience dans les affaires dans
le business dans les médias ni quoi que
ce soit ma mère y mon père algérien je
suis arrivé en france à l'âge de 5 ans
et en plus financièrement c'était
vraiment difficile mais il avait une
philosophie de la vie différente ils
nous ont dit à mon frère et moi il faut
que tu fasses les choses avec passion il
faut que tu suives tes rêves et si tu
fais vraiment ce que tu aimes dans la
vie pas ça marchera on a confiance dans
la vie et c'est quelque chose d'assez
inhabituel parce que temps normalement
les parents ont toujours peur il faut
que tu fasses des études ton futur et
même la société autour de nous est en
train de nous dire ne pense pas à tous
tes rêves soit sérieux etc et mes
parents il n'était pas branché comme ça
parce que la richesse pour eux c'était
une richesse psychologique c'était voilà
deux lettres de la connaissance et de la
psychologie et pas du tout une richesse
matérielle et donc ils avaient ils
croyaient en la vie et grâce à ça ça m'a
permis d'être d'être finalement d'avoir
aucun problème sur le doubs du futur
j'ai bien sûr je sais que je peux rater
plein de projets mais d'aborder la vie
différemment alors j'ai essayé tous les
métiers vous n'allez pas à l'école j'ai
fait la traversée alors en avant n'a
voyagé en plus avec mes parents j'ai
fait la traversée de l'atlantique en
voilier j'ai fait l'amazonie en pirogue
j'avais envie d'avoir un petit singe on
a eu un sage a pas restée les choses
complètement out of the box j'étais
magicien professionnel j'ai fait du
piano du tennis de l'acrobatie l'école
du cirque tous les choses inimaginables
et j'ai commencé le roller à l'âge de 5
ans avec mon frère et là tout de suite
j'ai dit à mes parents c'est ce que je
sais j'ai envie de devenir champion de
roller c'est ma passion et de vue qu'ils
avaient aucune peur ils m'ont dit écoute
si c'est vraiment ce que tu aimes on va
te soutenir effet le à fond alors je me
suis entraîné comme un diable pendant
des années et avait pas la mode du
roller pour exploser et heureusement
vers 20 ans la mode du roller hors ligne
a explosé en europe et je me suis
retrouvé du jour au lendemain sponsorisé
et j'ai commencé à réaliser ce rêve va
pouvoir vivre avec mon sport et donc
même pouvoir aider mes parents
financièrement parce qu'ils avaient des
problèmes financiers donc c'était super
je vivais de ma passion je voyais dans
le voyager dans le monde entier mais
évidemment c'était dangereux il y avait
des accidents j'ai commencé à me casser
le bras et les jambes j'ai été opéré
d'un genou trois fois des épaules de foi
des poignets de fois la hanche cassées
les cervicales presse trois fois le nez
trois fois ici ouvert les doigts les
vicois partout donc j'ai toujours à
l'hôpital et sur le devant de la scène
et à chaque fois que j'étais à l'hôpital
j'avais cette petite voix dû me dire il
faut que je pense à l'avenir parce que
j'ai aucun diplôme j'aide mes parents
financièrement j'ai pas vraiment
d'argent de côté donc il faut que je me
bouge donc j'ai commencé à créer des
boîtes à chaque fois que j'étais sur lit
d'hôpital ça n'a pas toujours marché
évidemment il ya eu des échecs j'ai
déposé le bilan comme
dans sur certaines boîtes mais c'est la
vie et après quand je suis revenu dans
mon sport après les accidents je me suis
dit il faut que je trouve une idée pour
amener mon image et celle de mon sport
auprès du grand public et vu que je suis
un rêveur je me suis dit allez voyons
les choses en grand et je me suis dit je
vais sauter par dessus la scène devant
notre-dame est à j'avais trouvé une idée
marketing parce que la scène est connu
du monde entier c'est devant notre-dame
et moi je vois que les choses positives
et je me dis c'est possible donc
j'essaye de convaincre le gouvernement
français on monte un dossier de 100
pages avec des ingénieurs je finance
tout avec le peu d'argent que j'avais je
présente sa et malheureusement les
institutions me dise messieurs crise est
pas possible et à chaque fois qu'ils me
ferment la porte moi je rentre par la
fenêtre avec un sourire et une nouvelle
idée je le redis attendait peut-être ici
à la scène c'est pas possible mais il ya
peut-être d'autres monuments à paris
alors la mairie de paris aller vers la
tour eiffel peut-être là bas c'est
possible moi j'entends même pas le
peut-être voyez je vais être eiffel je
m'entoure d'une équipe on refaire le
dossier de 100 pages et j'imagine un
énorme événement au pied de la tour
eiffel et je me rends compte ça va
coûter 1 million d'euros évidemment je
n'ai pas l'argent dont je commence à
contacter des sponsors et j'apprends à
faire du design sur photoshop pour
mettre en gros les logos des sponsors et
les sponsors me dise sérieusement situe
à la tour eiffel et des no logo en
énorme on te donne le budget et la
mairie de paris me dise monsieur crise y
aller loin en france il est interdit
d'afficher le moindre logo à côté d'un
monument historique est clairement la
tour eiffel soit monuments historiques
et donc à nouveau je me retrouve devant
un mur est toujours avec de
l'imagination j'arrive à trouver des
parades et donc lui imaginer la parade
que j'ai trouvé c'est de me dire je vais
créer un show télé et c'est moi qui
contrôlerait tous les caméras je m 15
caméraman et vu que c'est moi qui
contrôle show télé je pourrais filmée en
gros plan le logo qui sera que sur mon
t-shirt après quand même un million
d'euros pour un logo sur un tee shirt
c'est pas beau et c'est pas très grand
et donc j'ai regardé dans les textes de
loi c'était bien marquer que sur les
structures j'avais pas le droit de
mettre de logo mais c'était pas marqué à
la télé est donc en fait vu que je
contrôlais les images j'ai incruster des
logos en 3d sur les rampes donc sur
place il fait pas de logo et à la télé
il y avait des logos et là j'avais
trouvé la parade juridique pour y
arriver et voiliers sauf que le maire de
paris avec quand même peur et c'était un
précédent 6 me donner l'autorisation à
moi imaginer que je me tue en direct
devant tout le monde donc il avait peur
et ils voulaient pas au début me
recevoir et donc je je passe toutes mes
journées au pied de la mairie de paris
pour essayer de convaincre l'assistante
de me donner rendez-vous et à un moment
il craque et le maire de paris me donne
l'autorisation papa il me donne pas
l'autorisation d'abord il refuse
l'autorisation
l'aiim écrit une lettre et il me dit je
peux pas te donner l'autorisation parce
que je tu touches l'herbe du champ de
mars
et donc j'ai tout s'effondre pour moi je
n'ai pas l'autorisation toutes mes
équipes abandonnent en quelque sorte et
donc là je me dis je n'ai pas le droit
de toucher l'air donc il faut que je
trouve à nouveau une astuce est donc
l'ancienne idée je vous l'avais dit
c'est de faire un saut en longueur sur
le champ de mars et donc j'imagine
quelque chose de nouveau c'est de sauter
de la tour eiffel dans la rampe et
m'arrêter juste avant l'herbe puisque je
n'ai pas le droit de toucher l'herbe
alors plein de complexité j'arrive à 100
kilomètres à l'heure en bas de la rampe
je dois m'arrêter 11 mai on se met à 100
kilomètres à l'heure je me dis si la
mairie ne demande pas comment je fais
pour freiner et surtout je leur dis pas
et et là je rend complètement dingues
les institutions parce qu'il me donne
une liste de refus et moi je passe des
nuits blanches à apprendre à faire tous
les dossiers 3d que vous voyez là et je
leur donne toutes les solutions ils
disent par exemple tu peux pas fermer la
route en bas et bien très bien je
surélève la rampe et je fais un pont et
les voitures passent en dessous ils
disent tu peux pas toucher la tour
eiffel il n'y a aucune assurance au
monde qui va assurer la tour eiffel
imaginé que ma structure la fasse tomber
et donc je leur dis mais comment je peux
sauter de la tour eiffel si je perds je
vais pas monté à mains nues alors du
coup je trouve un astuces et de mettre
une nacelle qui s'arrête à 20
centimètres de la tour eiffel pour
donner l'illusion que la nacelle y est
accroché mais elle n'est pas en réalité
et comme je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
je passe mes journées au pied de la
mairie paris pour essayer de convaincre
le maire de paris elle donnait rendez
vous et il craque il accepte et je me
retrouve donc face au maire de paris
dans son bureau
et là bertrand me dit écoute moi j'ai
peur que tu en direct donc si tu veux
avoir l'autorisation tu dois me prouver
qu il ne t'arrivera rien mais personne
peut prouver sa voyez ce que je veux
dire je vais sauter de 40 mètres de haut
la rampe fait trente mètres les
championnats du monde la robe faisait 3
m donc ça ça n'a rien à voir et je dois
arrêter en plus etc etc mais il faut
quand même que je trouve une solution et
avec comme je voulais dit de
l'imagination on trouve toujours et donc
je dis au maire de paris je vais
construire une rampe d'entraînement sur
un terrain vague et je vais répéter le
sceau de mille fois le filmer et
envoyait la cassette vidéo maire de
paris tous les mois et donc s'il a une
vidéo où il me vois faire 500 fois le
même saut tous les mois pendant des mois
avec une équipe de techniques de
sécurité il peut se dire ça marche et
grâce à ça j'arrive à obtenir
l'impossible parce que c'est clairement
l'un possible de sauter de la tour
eiffel en tout cas l'autorisation est en
réalité c'est pas grâce à ça en réalité
je crois que vous l'avez compris la
façon où je m'exprime je suis passionnée
et donc j'ai réussi à embarquer chaque
personne de l'assistante de le directeur
technique du maire de paris à bord de
mon train et les touches et
émotionnellement et vraiment un conseil
que je pourrais vous donner dans la vie
c'est si vous êtes passionné vous
arrivez à transmettre cette passion vous
verrez que vous allez obtenir des choses
incroyables des gens que vous avez en
face de vous et je pense pas que dans
l'histoire en france en or avec
quelqu'un qui obtiendra la tour eiffel à
nouveau je pense ça n'arrivera plus
alors le problème quand même même si
j'avais eu l'autorisation j'avais pas
l'argent dont il y avait juste un
sponsor qui me dit je te donne l'argent
si la cie les français ne se qualifie
pas la coupe du monde de foot il y avait
thiriez à l'époque avait mis la main qui
avait qualifié la france donc j'avais
plus assez d'argent et je pouvais pas
faire l'événement donc il fallait à
nouveau trouvé un as une astuce
incroyable et c'est là où je vous dis
grâce un peu à ma façon de penser ma
philosophie je pense à hauteur de boxe
je me dis il faut trouver un astuces
extrême donc j'ai été voir tous les
fabricants et je leur ai dit faites-moi
gratuit et je vous assure ça marche et
un parent toujours avec la passion je
leur ai dit écoutez façon si vous
m'aidez pas ça se fera pas donc j'ai
réussi à les embarquer un par un et
faire des coupes de cent mille cinquante
mille etc à la fin je n'avais plus assez
d'argent j'avais un sponsor qui devait
me payer cette somme est donc j'ai mis
toutes mes économies pour mettre cent
cinquante mille euros pour faire le saut
dans que ça va coûter 150 mille euros
mais voyez un rêve n'a pas de prix je me
suis dit qu'est ce que je fais et ce que
j'ai envie d'avoir cent cinquante mille
euros à la banque et regretter toute ma
vie d'avoir sauté de la tour eiffel donc
je vais même pas réfléchi une seconde
j'ai diop c'était parti et là il ya le
vrai événement qui a commencé à se
construire et cette rampe qui fait 40 m
2 au pied de la tour eiffel qui a
commencé à se construire cent mille
personnes qui viennent voir le saut
voyez j'ai pas touché les arbres est du
champ de mars alors petite parenthèse
pas négligeable les deux mille sauts
j'ai pas pu les faire j'avais au final
pas assez d'argent et le maire de parier
à accepter et donc quand je me suis
retrouvé à 40 mètres de haut sur cette
nacelle qui tangue avec le vent bah je
l'avais jamais fait et je peux vous dire
que quand vous êtes à 40 mètres dans
cette nacelle qui tangue on n'est pas
fiers et donc j'ai j'ai manipulé mon
cerveau comme à la troisième personne je
me suis dit façon tu as pas de dégonfler
devant tout le monde tu va sauter donc
tu es peur vous pas peur le résultat va
être le même donc au point où tourner
autant de pas avoir peur que je veux
dire et je me suis dit ce qui peut
arriver normalement tu vas pas mourir
mais
normalement mais je me suis dit je vais
sûrement me casser un bras ou une jambe
et après je me suis dit ça m'est arrivé
tellement de fois c'est pas très grave
tu connais le processus des opérations
donc j'ai dédramatiser l'accident et le
troisième truc pour manipuler ce mon
cerveau je me suis dit c'est quand même
un des moments les plus magiques de ta
vie tu vas pas caché sa avec de la peur
et grâce à ça j'avais exorciser la peur
après le freinage était compliquée parce
que je fallait que je m'arrête en bas
bref c'était compliqué mais tu es génial
après il ya une autre vie un petit peu
de la d'aventurier dans des émissions il
ya eu des hauts et des bas et il ya six
ans l'arrière malheureusement tout s'est
effondré parce que je n'arrivais plus à
remonter des records j'avais des films
que j'avais essayé de monter que j'ai
pas pu monter et je me suis retrouvé à
nouveau sur le lit d'hôpital avec une
opération j'arrivais à 40 ans je me suis
dit je peux pas rester dans les sports
extrêmes toute ma vie il faut que
j'essaye de me réinventer et donc je me
suis dit il faut que je me lance dans
dans business dans une boîte qu'est ce
que je peux essayer d'inventer j'ai
essayé d'écrire une formule magique donc
si un jour vous voulez créer une boîte
noter là où fait un screenshot et donc
c'est une sorte de folk formule magique
au moins votre boîte sera sur des bonnes
bases c'est tout bête c'est choisir la
plus grande industrie au monde une
berries et cette industrie l'expérience
utilisateur est roi inventer quelque
chose qui n'existe pas facile à dire
mais pas à faire choisir une industrie
qui a une distribution mondiale etc et
donc je suis parti dans les télécoms une
idée dans les télécoms évidemment les
fonds d'investissement quand j'ai été
les voir avec mon idée ils m'ont rigolé
au nez parce que je voulais créer un
opérateur télécom j'étais en rôle quand
j'étais en béquilles et pour un rouleur
maniement pas donné un sou et du coup
qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai convaincu
tout mon entourage de me donner un peu
d'argent et j'ai convaincu comme ça 130
personnes qui m'ont donné 10 millions et
ça a pu démarrer un parent ges a pris
des années à les convaincre les fonds
d'investissement rajouter 10 millions
mais dix fois plus cher et donc j'ai
finalement créé deux boîtes je vais vous
les montrer voilà et donc il ya deux
applications il y en a une qui s'appelle
geoff qui permet d'avoir un deuxième
numéro en un clic sur votre portable
donc si vous voulez un numéro pro numéro
perso ou un numéro pour votre homme
voiture sur le bon coin vous téléchargez
un oeuf et en un clic vous avez un
deuxième numéro la deuxième c'est une
application un peu à la what's up de la
photo vous voulez un
album collaboratif entre potes au lieu
de créer un dans une conversation watson
pouvez faire ça donc voilà les deux
boîtes en les rentables on grandit on
est bientôt 80 est donc maintenant qu'on
a fait un peu le bilan de tout ça
j'imagine que vous dites mais pas
comment il a fait pour réaliser tous ces
choses ben je vais vous dire
la seule le seul le don en quelque sorte
que j'ai c'est l'éducation que mes
parents m'ont donné au début c'est cette
façon de voir la vie totalement sans
barrière qui me permet de d'aller
uniquement de l'avant sans les problèmes
je sais que je peux rater je peux finir
à l'hôpital je peux faire mes boîtes je
peux je peux rater mais la peur de
l'échec pour moi n'existe pas parce que
je sais que la peur est un sentiment
l'échec est réelle mais la peur est un
sentiment donc quand je me lève le matin
j'ai uniquement les toiles au loin du
rêve que j'ai envie d'atteindre et je
n'imagine jamais les problèmes à plus
d'une journée et finalement quand on
voit d'où je partais je n'avais pas
beaucoup d'expérience aucun diplôme etc
vous aujourd'hui vous avez la chance
d'avoir déjà un bagage et donc le
message voulez aujourd'hui vous dire
c'est simplement continuer évidemment
cette route qui est qui est génial dans
laquelle vous êtes mes reconnecter vous
avec vos passions vos rêves vous folie a
osé foire les choses en grand et là tout
est possible et à partir du moment où
vous reconnecter avec ça déjà vous allez
être heureux rappelez-vous ce qu'on m'en
dit mes parents quel que soit votre
métier si vous faites vraiment ce que
vous aimez ça marchera pour vous dans la
vie et je sais que dans cette période de
covili a parfois on a des doutes
personnel où on est dans le noir où il
ya des difficultés il ya un petit
problème que j'ai écrit pour ça parce
que j'ai été souvent dans le noir au
fond du gouffre comme je le dis là eh
ben quand on est dans une difficulté si
on se rattache à un rêve à une passion
eh bien on peut être honte où la
difficulté c'est tout le monde devient
vert autour de nous puisque on oublie
les problèmes et un deuxième chose que
beaucoup de gens me demander c'est
comment on fait quel secret finalement
pour toucher les étoiles c'est le haweij
pour ça que j'ai écrit ça également
c'est en réalité j'avais dans mon sport
des mecs qui était mille fois plus doués
que moi mais le travail acharné est
imbattable donc voilà c'était juste que
je voulais vous communiquer aujourd'hui
chacun choisit sa vie je vous dis pas de
devenir champion de roller aujourd'hui
faites nous rêver c'est à vous
maintenant l'avenir est entre vos mains
mais faites le avec passion avec travail
avec rêves et vous serez heureux
merci
[Applaudissements]